well their long-term changes that we
need to think about I talk in the book a
lot about this idea of deliberative
democracy of direct democracy if you
will of reclaiming politics for
ourselves and moving away in many
respects from representative government
which is so easily captured but I think
in the in the in the shorter run there's
a lot that we need to do before we can
realize a longer term objectives I mean
at first there a long list of political
reforms that we need to be attending to
you know nonpartisan congressional
districts the treaty among the states
that moves us to direct election of the
president or by popular vote getting
money out of out of politics so the
clean and fair elections that are
publicly financed the citizen right to
the airwaves there are lots and lots of
reforms that we need to make of our
political system I mean just look at the
primary mess that we are in today in our
presidential elections and and they're
even in the voting in in Pennsylvania
there were a lot of problems with people
you know showing up and not being
properly registered at the voting places
so so there's a long list of political
reforms that need to be made in terms of
environmental politics I think the
environmental community has been has
badly neglected electoral politics it's
been as I said it's been a movement that
focused on working the political system
that's there we haven't focused on
changing the political system itself and
including changing those in the
political system who are elected and
that's different from a lot of other
concerns that our country is people have
had in our country but it has not been a
strong force in electoral politics that
we've got to change that it has been an
isolated concern it has not built
bridges to many other communities in our
in our country and you know there's very
little interaction or shared work
between those who are concerned about
environment and those who are concerned
about social justice and those who are
concerned about political reform these
are separate communities and everybody's
in their silo and this is not good
environmental community is also much
more comfortable in this mainstream in
developing wonkish proposals for policy
action than it is in framing messages
that really resonate with lots of people
and as a result we've lost a lot of
support among the public and we're not
talking to people and and we're so when
we see people coming along and talking
about jobs for all and green collar jobs
and things like that is very encouraging
because they're trying to break down
that insularity if you will of the
established environmental groups so and
and then lastly we've got to really
build a grassroots movement I really
other than some fairly devastating
crisis that could change things and wake
everybody up and even that won't work
unless it happens at a time of wise
leadership which we haven't had the only
beyond that the real prospect for
changes is it would be a social movement
in the country of the the gathering of
forces forgive me beginning with young
people people
cerned about the climate issue religious
organizations increasingly involved
concerned citizens of all types coming
together and then reaching across these
different communities and coming
together and an insisting that we take
back our democracy we reassert these
these human and natural values into the
system before it's too late